Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my new mandalorian season 2 video
all about boba fett his history and the easter
eggs from the episode i'm doing videos for
all the season 2 episodes so if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all them we'll do a new disney plus membership
giveaway all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave all your boba fett
predictions for season 2 on the video so obviously
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet but we'll just start with the
big stuff and work our way down the list number
five is the mandalorian takes boba fett's
armor from cobb vanth they make a couple references
to the damage that it's sustained recently
in historical damage from the star wars movies
and books tell your people that i wasn't the
one that did that to the armor so there's
a dent in the armor from where boba fett got
hit on jabba's sail barge mando also hits
him on his armor to the same place where han
solo hit him there's damage on his helmet
from cad bane and if you didn't watch the
clone wars cad bane also mentored boba fett
as a bounty hunter when he got a little bit
older boba fett appeared as a child during
the events of the clone wars dave filoni actually
revealed back at star wars celebration 2015
that there was going to be this five episode
arc where boba fett and cad bain were traveling
around together in future episodes but that
never wound up getting made they did make
a lot of the episodes that dave filoni talked
about for the clone wars season seven but
the cadbane boba fett stuff didn't make it
in because they were mostly focused on finishing
the bad batch episodes that they had already
done work on there were a bunch of uncompleted
episodes when the show was canceled they also
just announced one of the new animated series
that they're doing is based on those bad batch
characters after the events of the clone wars
season seven and then they also wanted to
wrap up the ahsoka storyline the darth maul
storylines in the clones storyline just telling
the story of order 66 from their perspective
crossing over with the events of revenge of
the sith execute order 66. if you haven't
seen those episodes i did videos for those
they're on my channel they were fantastic
but for those of you asking after season one
because there were a lot of theories about
who showed up at the end of season one episode
five now we know who it was but there were
a lot of people at the time that thought it
could also be cad bane because he also wears
the same type of spurs that you heard jingling
across the sand as he was walking up to fanuc
shan's body and for those of you wondering
dave filoni did reveal that the cad bang character
did survive the events of the clone wars and
eventually went on to serve the empire so
he's still alive during the events of the
mandalorian and could always show up on the
series at some point but number four big stuff
as the mandalorian rides across the twin suns
sunset varies star wars a new hope tamara
morrison returns as boba fett without his
armor watching from a vantage point in the
same clothing that we saw him in from the
end of season 1 episode 5 now knowing that
it was him after all at the time the episode
aired last year i felt like that was what
they were going for like why else would you
put the spurs on the boots and make them jingle
that way if you didn't want people to think
that it was boba fett just like a classic
gunslinger would the episode was titled the
gunslinger which at the time was mostly a
reference to the mandalorian toro and mingnas
fennec shand character but it was also a clever
reference to boba fett coming back because
he's a gunslinger and they always knew that
they were going to do him during season two
his face doesn't betray any emotion he's stone
cold but he's probably been monitoring cobb
vanth this whole time just waiting for an
opportunity to take his armor back and then
all of a sudden the mando and baby yoda show
up so now he's following them not only because
he wants to take his armor back but probably
because baby yoda has also piqued his curiosity
and you have to remember that he's still a
bounty hunter he would know about the bounties
that had been out on mando and baby yoda in
the past as of episode 1 we don't really know
if moff gideon has an active bounty out on
them right now but i'll address boba fett
potentially working for moff gideon in a second
because you have the whole boba fett working
for darth vader all the references to empire
strikes back it just implied that eventually
those three or four characters including baby
yoda will have a great gunslinger standoff
at some point in the series the good the bad
and the ugly if we're talking about big western
movies mando being the clint eastwood character
the good moff gideon the bad and boba fett
the ugly because now he's literally scarred
from the damage he sustained in the sarlacc
pit the city miles version of boba fett and
for those of you asking yes obviously it's
possible that rex could show up on the series
because he's still alive after the events
of return of the jedi too he would also be
played by tamora morrison he plays all the
clones that's sort of the trick of star wars
he is the clone number three but how did boba
fett survive the sarlacc pit during the episode
the tuscan raiders explain how the crate dragon
species eats sarlacc and this particular krait
dragon ate this sarlacc and that's why it's
using its lair as its home also for a lot
of you that were wondering yes that whole
crate dragon part of the episode is directly
ripped out of a knights of the old republic
mission that you go on to get a crate dragon
pearl jon favreau is the one that wrote the
episode so apparently he's a huge fan of knights
of the old republic because this area this
sarlacc pit is in close proximity to where
the jawas scavenged boba fett's armor and
found cobb vanth boba fett probably escaped
when the sarlacc he was in got eaten or was
in the process of getting eaten by a crate
dragon that's a big callback reference to
a phantom menace where qui-gon jinn says there's
always a bigger fish as a bunch of successively
larger fish come along eating the smaller
fish and speaking of water references underwater
they're in the dune sea and the crate dragon
also travels underneath the sand underneath
the dune sea it doesn't absolutely confirm
that this particular sarlacc pit is the exact
one that boba fett escaped from but it could
have been the tusken raiders say that they've
been tracking this particular crate dragon
for generations following its cycles just
following it around as it moved about tatooine
hunting but it's implied that boba fett barely
escaped with his life lost his armor in the
process of the escape but the best scar armor
being super strong is what helped him survive
in the sarlacc for so long but because cobb
vanth said that he got boba fett's armor within
a couple weeks of the end of return of the
jedi you also have to assume that the jawa
scavenged it right after the events of return
of the jedi so boba fett himself wasn't in
the sarlacc for that long number two big question
what will boba fett's storyline be other than
reclaiming his armor and becoming a bounty
hunter again maybe in trying to reclaim his
armor they'll try to redeem the character
after his poor showing in return of the jedi
in the hilarious way he went out there was
this whole joke about return of the jedi in
the fandom that he's meant to be the most
fearsome bounty hunter in the galaxy they
hype him up all through empire strikes back
you have that crazy ending with han solo going
into the carbonite then they hilariously take
boba fett out in a funny way in the sarlacc
pit at the very beginning of return of the
jedi and that's the last you hear the character
like well i guess he wasn't so badass after
all part of what they did during season 2
episode 1 was try to redeem the tuscan raider
characters like no they're not exactly the
way that the movies have portrayed them in
the past they're way cooler than you thought
that they were so i feel like that's what
they're doing with the boba fett character
during season two possibly season three and
other seasons is try to show you why he's
the most fearsome bounty hunter in the galaxy
you also have the idea of real mandalorians
versus fake mandalorians with that whole cobb
vanth twist in the episode the way he took
his helmet off so quickly in the mando's insistence
that part of their code states that only real
mandalorians have the right to wear that armor
john favreau himself describes the boba fett
character as not a true mandalorian in the
context of the star wars movies in his history
just someone who wears mandalorian armor and
doesn't necessarily follow their code so i
feel like that's the biggest teaser he could
give you for a huge mandalorian versus boba
fett fight at some point during the series
whether or not it happens during season 2
or season 3 remains to be seen but whatever
they do with the boba fett character in terms
of painting him as a villain or an antagonist
during season two i do like the idea that
they eventually want him to reclaim his quote-unquote
honor as he's reclaiming his armor so it's
possible that eventually if they don't turn
him into a crazy big villain in the future
of the series he'll also try to reclaim some
of his heritage technically as a genetic mandalorian
because jango fett at one time was a mandalorian
but then he got kicked out so technically
boba fett couldn't call himself a mandalorian
at this point in the series you also have
the idea that tomorrow morrison is getting
a little bit older so it's a little harder
for him to film those epic boba fett level
action sequences that you would want to see
happen but that's why you would eventually
give him the armor back so that when he wears
it and then goes off the chain you could put
a stunt person anybody you want in the costume
underneath the helmet and just have him do
the voice over parts so you get your epic
boba fett fight scenes with the mandalorian
i feel like all the cobb van mando team-up
scenes during episode one are a good teaser
for what that might be like so if cobb vanth
has only had the armor for a couple years
and he's already this good with it think about
how boba fett is going to be when he gets
his armor back i also want to see tamara morrison
put that helmet on for the first time just
to see the look on his face when he gets his
armor back the number one what about ahsoka
where is ahsoka tano if all the major news
sites were reporting rosario dawson had been
cast to play her in the last year well a lot
of you may have noticed that dave filoni wrote
and directed season 2 episode 5 he's the person
that created the ahsoka character during the
clone wars series with george lucas one of
the rumored temporary working titles for an
episode in season two was quote unquote the
sorcerer which is a reference to the jedi
that the armor and the mandalorian make they
were really big about including a lot of that
dialogue in the season 2 trailer just letting
you know we will eventually see some jedi
this season or people who used to be jedi
because technically ahsoka isn't a jedi but
i'll be doing more mandalorians season 2 and
star wars bonus videos next week leave all
your requests and big questions in the comments
below congratulations jay knight you're the
giveaway winner for my last big star wars
video everyone click here for my full mandalorian
season 2 episode 1 video and everyone click
here for my new thor 4 marvel avengers video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe this is the way!